à 10h26 heure de pékin soit un peu plus
de 22h heure de l'est
le module tu chantes 4 du nom de la
déesse de la lune dans la mythologie
chinoise s'est posé sans problème sur la
face cachée de l'astre l'engin qui a
quitté la terre le 8 décembre a touché
le sol pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la conquête spatiale
sur cette partie de la lune s'est
déroulé comme prévu l'alunissage s'est
passé sur notre point d'atterrissage
idéal en d'autres termes nous n'avons
pas manqué notre cible
la chine se préparait depuis des années
à cette opération particulièrement
difficile du point de vue technologique
et pour augmenter la difficulté de la
mission le module a été envoyé au pôle
sud lunaire une région au relief escarpé
la face cachée de la lune a beaucoup de
ressources
nous pourrons mieux comprendre la
formation et l'évolution de la lune
nous maîtrisons la technologie
d'alunissage sur ces endroits
l'objectif de cette mission étudier les
basses fréquences radio les ressources
en minéraux de la lune et tester la
culture des tomates et d'autres plans je
pense que nos efforts d'exploration de
la lune ne cesseront pas dit l'ingénieur
en chef du programme
ils continueront avec plus de dévouement
et plus de plans à long terme
le programme spatial chinois piloté par
l'armée ambitionne l'année prochaine
d'envoyer un autre module chante 5 sur
la lune
sa mission serait essentiellement de
collecter des échantillons et de les
ramener sur terre avant de lancer sa
propre station spatiale prévue en 2022
ici à ce mitraillage radio canada
montréal